le sort qui est réservé à richard ferron
est quand même assez curieux parce qu'on
laisse fillon l'ex filtre du
gouvernement pour des affaires et ont le
même président du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale alors que le parlement va
entamer sa va commencer au sénat
d'ailleurs la discussion sur la loi de
moralisation enfin elle s'appelle plus
comme ça la loi pour retrouver confiance
dans l'action publique
donc tout ça effectivement état c est
assez étrange étrange et rouge
est-ce qu'il est étrange également que
françois bayrou reste au gouvernement
pour défendre cette loi alors que sa
collègue du modem comme lui également
cité dans l' enquête sur les assistants
parlementaires payé par papa par le
parlement européen et sur la fleur des
assistants parlementaires européens
allaient les ogm sont courroucés pas
très bien d'ailleurs si finalement ils
vont être mis en cause ou pas les
procédures sont assez longs au parlement
européen ce qui ce qui est effectivement
une enquête de la justice
effectivement perturbant c'est que on a
des ministres qui vont être au front sur
la question de la moralisation de la vie
publique qui sont eux mêmes concernés
ça renforce des propositions que nous
allons porter d'ailleurs nous dans le
débat parlementaire pour améliorer
encore les dispositions transparence les
dispositions de prévention des conflits
d'intérêts voilà surtout ça il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire débat
parlementaire nous permettra de faire
adopter des propositions plus audacieuse
que celle que qui figure pour le moment
dont l'acquéreur dont le projet là bien
vernon mais vous dites
étrange perturbant mais répondez moi
est-ce que vous demander le départ de
françois bayrou et de marielle de sarnez
qui sont tous les deux cités dont je
pense alors des affaires du gouvernement
j'ai pas de raison de demander le départ
leur françois bayroux par exemple du
gouvernement est ce que vous trouvez
néanmoins que la situation devient
gênante pour emmanuel macron ou alors
est-ce que vous lui accorder un crédit
supplémentaire ou à crédit tout court
d'ailleurs non mais ils essayent je
pense depuis le début que contrairement
à ce qu'on annonce cette majorité de
n'est pas une majorité de vrai renouveau
politique et
et tous les élus qu'on nous présente
comme venant de la société civile tout
ça en vérité sont très liés sont très
liés au mieux aux milieux économiques au
milieu aux milieux dirigeants du pays il
déjà ce donc bien qu'ils pensaient tout
ça mais je pense en général à la
majorité des manuels macro je pense
qu'on va découvrir progressivement qu'on
est très très loin du renouveau
politique annoncée et je pense que ça ça
remettra les choses à leur juste place
il y aurait des choses plus profondes à
faire pour renouveler la représentation
politique à propos de renouvellement est
par exemple la proportionnelle d'accord
ce que c'est un débat reviendra